[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY GROVE: Google for
Entrepreneurs is our umbrella
effort of all of Google's
programs and partnerships that
support startups and
entrepreneurs around the world.
Today, we have roughly 50
different efforts live in over
30 countries around the world.
On the partnership front,
we work with an amazing
organization called
Startup Weekend.
They're a team that puts on
these 54-hour weekend events.
They'd hack throughout the
weekend and launch companies
on Sunday night.
One of my favorite programs is
called Jagriti Yatra, and it's
a train ride across rural India
with about 400 really
energized youth and mentors.
They discuss and they iterate
and they get off really
inspired and ready to go out
there and implement that idea.
Women Entrepreneurs on the Web
is a program to get female
entrepreneurs onto the web to
help build and market and then
[? scale ?] their businesses.
ARCHANA DOSHI: It's a great
place to get ideas, great
place to network with
women who are
pursuing their passion.
MARY GROVE: We're really excited
about a number of
programs across the Middle
East and North Africa.
With our local office in Tel
Aviv, we're seeing a lot of
opportunities for technology
and entrepreneurship, like
hackathons with both Palestinian
and Israeli youth,
for example.
Campus London is one of our
most exciting initiatives.
EZE VIDRA: It's a seven-story
building filled with startups,
where startups can get
workspace, access events,
mentorship, all under
one roof.
MALE SPEAKER: Having an
environment like this, you
have specialists
in each field.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I would never
have had the chance to meet
people who were developers,
who were designers.
There isn't anywhere else
where you can do this.
MARY GROVE: There's a huge
opportunity to continue to
make an impact, to
scale this work.
And we really want to empower
the next generation of
entrepreneurs and startups
to be successful.
DEREK SLATER: Welcome back to
a Google Developers Live.
My name's Derek Slater, and I
defend the open internet on
Google's Public Policy team.
Yesterday, we talked about
measurement tools that can
empower users to know more about
what's happening online
and how they can help defend
and protect the
free and open internet.
Today we want to talk more about
the economic impact of
the internet and,
specifically,
entrepreneurship.
We're joined here by two guests,
John Lyman from Google
for Entrepreneurs and Mike
McGeary from Engine Advocacy.
And we'll start by just having
the two of them introduce
themselves before we talk about
the economic impact of
the internet and the policies
that affect it.
John, why don't we
start with you?
JOHN LYMAN: Thanks, Derek, and
thank you for having us on the
show today.
I'm really excited to talk
about entrepreneurship.
I work on the Google for
Entrepreneurs team.
I've been at Google for
about five years.
Before that was in Washington,
D.C., so I've got a tech and
policy background.
DEREK SLATER: And John, why
don't you tell us-- what is
Google for Entrepreneurs?
What's the program about?
JOHN LYMAN: So Google for
Entrepreneurs launched
publicly in September
of this year.
And our mission is to empower
entrepreneurs across the world
through products, partnerships,
and programs.
We work with groups as diverse
as Startup Weekend, which
launches businesses and products
in 54-hour weekend
sessions across the world and
groups like Campus London,
which is a seven-story building
that Google owns and
operates in East London.
It's a tech hub where
entrepreneurs and startups are
working, and accelerators and
others in the space are coming
together to help them
do their job.
And it really grew out of a
sense that executives had at
Google that we were-- as a
company having relationships
with a lot of different
incubators, accelerators, tech
hubs globally-- it was happening
in a very grassroots
way, which is a specialty of
Google's, I would say.
But they wanted to figure out,
OK, what are we really getting
out of these relationships?
What makes sense?
How can we help entrepreneurs
the most?
So they created a small team,
which is now Google for
Entrepreneurs, to really look
across everything and figure
out, OK, what's happening and
how can we make sure that
we're bringing Google's products
and tools to bear in
the way that makes
the most sense?
And we're doing it for
a few reasons.
As people know by now, Google
itself started in a garage,
and we think there are a lot of
other people out there who
are doing the same thing.
We'd like to help them.
Larry and Sergey, the founders
of Google, believe that they
had a lot of help
along the way.
Silicon Valley's a great place
to start a business, but we
wanted to help others who are
outside of Silicon Valley do
the same thing.
And we believe we're
a startup at heart.
We think that we move quickly,
and we're trying to infuse
those values into others.
We acquire a lot of companies
here in Silicon Valley but
also globally.
And we want to make sure that
when people come here, they
feel comfortable as
entrepreneurs.
More than 2/3 of entrepreneurs,
founders, that
come from companies that Google
has acquired actually
still work here, which we view
as a very, very good thing.
And we found entrepreneurs all
over the world who we're
excited to work with.
We estimate that there are
more than 400 million
entrepreneurs globally, and we
think that 70 million of those
are working in early-stage
ventures on new
products and services.
And we're trying to reach them
in a variety of different ways
and give them all the help that
they need and tell them
about Google.
DEREK SLATER: Great.
Thanks, John.
So Mike, why don't you tell us
about Engine Advocacy, sort of
what it's about, where it
came from, and what
you're doing this year.
MICHAEL MCGEARY: Well
thanks, Derek.
It's great to be here today
with all of you on Google
Developers Live.
I'm Michael McGeary.
I'm the co-founder, political
director, and senior
strategist for Engine
Advocacy.
We are a nonprofit based in
San Francisco here in the
United States.
And our goal is to effect
better public policy by
leveraging the voices and
stories of the startup
community and help educate both
startups about government
and government about startups.
We got started last year,
slightly before many here in
the US did, around the SOPA/PIPA
fight and around
some of the copyright
fights that were
happening in Congress.
But that was actually slightly
away from our core mission,
which is really to act in a
positive and forward-thinking
way to find better policy
alternatives where we can on a
range of different issues.
And the reason is very simple.
And as John alluded to
previously, entrepreneurs and
the businesses built on the
internet and disruptive,
technology-focused startups
really do power the economy in
America and, in many cases,
around the world as well.
And what we want to do is make
it a little easier for those
businesses to take root and to
get more of those stories to
effect that policy
and grow those
businesses going forward.
We have a whole range of
issues that we work on,
including things like high-skill
immigration in the
US, patent, spectrum and
broadband deployment.
But one of the reasons that I'm
here today-- and I think
it's vitally important that
we're having this
conversation--
is that without a free and
open internet, it doesn't
matter what other issues we work
on because innovation in
this country will be chilled in
a way that we haven't seen
and in a way that would be
totally detrimental to the
internet and to the economy
on the whole.
So that is really a
core issue for us.
It's what brought us to the
SOPA/PIPA copyright fight
earlier this year and
late last year.
And it's what guides us in terms
of how we think about
the issues that we tackle and
the issues that we want the
startup community to lend their
voices to in helping
create better policy.
So that's the background
on us.
We've been going now for
a little over a year.
We've got members all around
the country who have done
things as diverse as sign
letters to Congress and meet
regulators in our office in San
Francisco or take their
story to Capitol Hill.
And we're looking to do more
of that in the coming
Congress, and I think we'll
probably talk a little bit
about today some things we can
expect there on a range of
policy issues.
But we're excited to be part
of the ecosystem and help
startups and government connect
in a more meaningful
and powerful way when it
comes public policy.
DEREK SLATER: Thanks, Mike.
I think one of the interesting
things about Engine that we've
seen over the last year is
entrepreneurship being more of
a central focus in public
policy, which, in many ways,
isn't necessarily a natural fit
for the tech community.
What do you think is now
shifting in terms of
entrepreneurs getting
more involved?
Do you see that it's hard as
their resistance to sort of
getting involved?
MICHAEL MCGEARY: I think that
it's become a little bit more
in vogue for entrepreneurs
to be a part of this.
SOPA was a real catalyst
for that.
But a lot of what we've done
over the last year, and
alongside people here at Google
and in other places all
across the internet, has been
really to try to turn that
moment into a movement.
And really to try and capitalize
off a lot of the
good stuff we did and a lot of
the good feelings that came
out of that in order to continue
that discussion and
continue to get people from
the startup community,
entrepreneurial community,
more involved in their
government.
And on the flip side of that--
in working with members of
Congress and their staff and
with regulators and with
people at the White House and
right on down to state and
local governments as well--
I'm finding more and more that
there's a new currency in
politics in a lot of ways
in that the stories that
entrepreneurs and investors and
people from this community
can lend really carry
a lot of weight.
Not just in terms of building
better legislation, but in
terms of better understanding
and building better
relationships between members of
Congress, their staff, and
an entrepreneur so that a
member or a staffer or a
regulator has better
understanding of exactly how
tech powers the economy and how
their influence really can
be felt in terms
of the debate.
And beyond that, I think that
understanding also has a
backbone in some
of the economic
data that we're seeing.
We're going to release a study
tomorrow that says, in no
small part, that
entrepreneurship is really
happening everywhere, just
as John was saying.
I know you'll probably
talk more about that.
But entrepreneurship is taking
root, not just here in Silicon
Valley and in New York,
but in communities
all across the country.
That's something that speaks
to 435 members of the House
and a hundred US senators.
That's something that everyone
can take a hold of and say,
this is happening in my
community and I want
to help that out.
So that's the message that we're
really working with the
community to try to push, and
it's been well received on
both sides.
DEREK SLATER: So John,
you talked about how
entrepreneurship isn't just
something for Silicon Valley
or Silicon Alley or even the US,
and you've worked with a
bunch of communities
around the world.
On the public policy side, we
certainly get asked by many
different policy makers-- how
can I grow Silicon Valley
where I am, whether
that's in Idaho or
in France or wherever?
What's your take on
that question?
Are there commonalities that
you see of successful
communities?
And are there things that
policymakers can do or
shouldn't do in order
to help grow the
same sort of ecosystem?
JOHN LYMAN: Yeah, absolutely.
We get this question
a lot as well.
And I think there's some things
that people across the
spectrum agree on are probably
necessary, not always
sufficient, for some sort of
innovation hub to exist.
It's usually proximity to
a university, probably a
research university.
Good infrastructure, so things
like highways, fast broadband
speeds, so that people can
actually get to where they
need to get physically
and electronically.
A lot of times--
it sounds a little bit weird--
but some sort of
counterculture that appears on
the scene, usually before the
hub itself.
So if you look at places that
are hotbeds of innovation in
the US and also globally,
Silicon Valley, obviously,
Boulder, Austin, Boston,
New York, Seattle.
These are places that usually
have a little bit of
counterculture.
That's usually something that
government can't help that
much with, but they can get
out of the way sometimes.
So things like that.
And then there are other factors
that I think haven't
been researched as much
but are interesting.
So non-compete agreements, for
example, are not particularly
enforceable in California.
Meaning that when people go
to a company and sign an
agreement that prevents them
from leaving and taking
information with them freely
and openly, those are less
enforceable in California
than in other parts.
Which means that when people
leave jobs, they take some
knowledge with them about how
things worked at other
companies and that helps with
the free flow of information.
I think what's really
interesting is that, in many
ways, this is the
internet itself.
The internet started at
research universities.
It had a lot of free information
flowing between
different people.
It was counter-cultural.
Infrastructure was
very important.
So I think those are all things
that can be done to
help create these
hubs globally.
One point I wanted to follow up
on that Michael made, which
I think is really important, is
entrepreneurs getting more
involved in policy.
So SOPA/PIPA was a great example
of people actually
really coming together and
making change, and I think
that was important.
I think entrepreneurs like to
be able to see that they can
have an impact.
SOPA/PIPA, great example.
Here in San Francisco, some of
the work that Twitter and Ron
Conway did--
there was a victory
there, right?
Twitter was going to leave
San Francisco.
Now they are not going to leave
because of a policy change.
Another example yesterday out
of Washington, D.C. That I
thought was really interesting
was Uber--
worked through the system and
are now going to be allowed to
operate their car ride service
without interference.
But they were able to get
a policy win through a
grassroots movement, essentially
of users, who
said, this is a really important
service to us and we
want to contact our policymakers
and make sure
that innovation is allowed
to spread.
MICHAEL MCGEARY: And if I could
just launch off of that
for a second--
I think you're absolutely right,
John, in that point.
And we actually wrote something
on our site this
morning by our policy analyst,
Ed Goodman, on this, which is
that we can disagree on things,
but that does not mean
we should disengage as a
startup community, as
entrepreneurs.
In fact, it means we should
engage even further in a lot
of ways because, as we saw,
especially with the Uber
example, is when the company
went and worked to make a
policy alternative, in reality
it worked out.
Now that's not going
to be every case.
We're not always going to win
like we did on Prop E or like
on SOPA/PIPA.
Prop E is the San Francisco
initiative on
the ballot last November.
And some of these victories that
we're going to have are
going to be much, much longer
slogs than a blackout on
January 18 and a bill getting
pulled on January 20.
That was light speed in
Congress, as was JOBS Act, as
with so many of the great
victories we've had over the
last year here in the US.
But it's important to stay
engaged in that fight.
It's important for entrepreneurs
to be a part of
that because, as we've seen,
when they lend their
particular viewpoint and angle
to that story, it really does
change the debate in very
meaningful ways.
DEREK SLATER: Well, let's talk
about one part of the JOBS Act
for a second, particularly
on crowd funding.
That's been a big issue
over the last year.
And it's sort of similar to
what's been happening with
Uber and Airbnb, where we
have these network-based
businesses, these communities
being formed, where the law is
sometimes a little
bit out of step.
What happened with the JOBS
Act and its crowd funding?
Where does that stand now?
Are there things, Mike, that
developers, entrepreneurs, who
are watching this can do in
order to help move that along?
MICHAEL MCGEARY: Well, I think
that JOBS Act, again, went
through Congress in a very
partisan year, during a very
partisan election, and did
so in about six weeks.
If you look at the calendar from
when the majority leader
in the House, Eric Cantor, and
some of his colleagues first
proposed the bill to when the
President signed it in the
Rose Garden, it was all
of about six weeks.
And, again, that really is
light speed in the United
States Congress and for
getting things done in
Washington.
However, that bill
is not yet law.
There are still regulations that
have to be put forth by
the Securities and Exchange
Commission on crowd funding,
on a few other pieces of that
bill, in order for it to
become a reality.
And for what a lot of people
from the entrepreneurial
community would like to see in
terms of crowd funding become
part of the law and become
something where people can see
real and direct benefit
off of it.
That process is still ongoing.
There are still ways to--
as an entrepreneur or as a
developer, as someone who
works at a startup that could
benefit from crowd funding--
are still ways to be part
of that debate.
And you can log a comment with
the Securities and Exchange
Commission.
And that's something that is
ongoing, especially on the
crowdfunding piece.
We hope that the SEC will
promulgate those rules early
in the new year and really
start working towards a
solution so that we
can finally see
that become a reality.
But it's not there yet.
Despite how much work this
community's already put in
there, there's still a little
bit more to do.
But when we get there, if we're
able to, again, lend our
collective voice to this debate
and help shape the law
in a way that will work best for
us, I think that'll be the
most positive outcome overall
for entrepreneurs.
JOHN LYMAN: And I think that's
interesting that you bring
that up because, I think finally
can people engage to
shape what happens, but I think
they can also engage and
hopefully speed it up a bit.
We're hearing from entrepreneurs
that it's taken
a bit longer than they thought
to actually get regulations
put around crowd funding.
I think it's going to be
important for entrepreneurs.
And these are not, again,
entrepreneurs in New York, in
Silicon Valley, who oftentimes
have access to financial
resources and venture capital
that others don't.
But these are the entrepreneurs
in Omaha who are
trying to do an angel round with
friends and family and
want a platform to be able to
do that a little bit more
easily than they
have right now.
So I'm really interested to see
where this goes and hope
that it happens quickly.
DEREK SLATER: John, one
of the things you
talked about was culture.
And another key issue that's
certainly been coming up over
the last month, and looks like
will be on the front burner in
2013, is immigration.
For both of you-- what is
the outlook within the
entrepreneurs' community?
What do you hear about
in terms of
immigration, visa issues?
Is this sort of a front-burner
issue for entrepreneurs these
days in the Valley?
And what are the hopes and
desires for what entrepreneurs
want out of immigration
reform here in the US?
JOHN LYMAN: Yeah, I think
it's a huge issue.
I hear about it quite a bit,
more so, I think, in some ways
than almost any other
policy issue.
So one quick example.
I have a friend who's a
recruiter in the Valley.
And as a lot of developers
know, recruiters are the
lifeblood, in some ways, of
the Valley because they're
effectively and efficiently
taking talent from one place
and deploying it in another.
So they see a lot of resumes.
They talk to a lot of
people, and they
understand this issue firsthand.
This friend went to SoundCloud
for a year, which is one of
the most successful startups
based in Germany.
It's in Berlin.
And when she recruited there,
she recruited globally.
She had two requirements,
essentially,
that she had to meet.
She had to meet the technical
requirements for the
engineering position, so the
coding languages, and then,
usually, people had
to speak English.
And that was it.
And she had engineers from India
and Eastern Europe and
Russia and Africa and
all over, Americans.
She moved back about eight
months ago and she's at
Square, which is one of the
most successful American
startups around right now.
Immediately, she stopped
recruiting globally.
She just doesn't want
to mess with it.
She can't get visas.
It slows her down.
And so she only recruits
in the US.
Now there's a lot of talent in
the US, but there's obviously
more talent globally,
and Michael can
speak to these numbers.
But I think what ends up
happening is when these jobs
at Square--
when they're filled and when
they're filled with good
talent-- that helps Square,
which is an American company,
but it also helps innovation
in general.
And it helps the local ecosystem
as other jobs are
created when those jobs are
filled with the right people.
So, yeah, incredibly important
issue and one that I hope the
Congress addresses.
MICHAEL MCGEARY: Well, I can't
agree with that enough.
And I think that we're looking
at a situation, not just here
in Silicon Valley and in New
York, but we're looking at
entrepreneurial communities
throughout the country that
are suffering right now.
And to say that immigration is
a top-line issue, it may be
the only issue in
a lot of cases.
As you said, John, and I can
speak to the numbers as we'll
have in the report tomorrow.
But with each job that's created
at a technology firm,
whether it's here in Mountain
View or at San Francisco, New
York, wherever, we can look and
create an average of 4.3
jobs in the non-tradable
sector.
So let's dig down from the
economics textbook here.
What's a non-tradable sector?
It's everything from barbers
to plumbers to doctors and
lawyers and yes, even bankers,
and all of the things that
make a community run,
restaurants, you name it.
And these are the kind of jobs
that are created when a
technology company moves in or
when a startup is created.
And we're also looking at a
situation where these startups
can't fill their talent
gap fast enough.
They can't get more people out
of the universities and into
jobs fast enough to develop the
products that are really
changing the economy.
And we talked--
Derek talked a little bit about
some of the [? peer ?]
economy, things like Etsy and
Airbnb and Square and others
that are powering other
businesses as well.
The faster that those businesses
and others like
them get created and more
businesses are created on top
of them, the better off
we're going to be.
They can't do that
without talent.
So this is why immigration
and, also, education--
investment in science,
technology, engineering, and
mathematics--
is vital to the long-term health
and success of the
American economy.
And if we don't fix immigration
in the near term,
and we don't invest in education
in the long term, we
are going to be met with a gap
between the vacancies that we
have and the jobs that we could
create and the jobs that
just won't be there--
and the talent that's
not there to fill
them, I should say.
So we can talk about the
individual stories, as well,
of entrepreneurs.
We know many of them.
In my line at work--
so I have a day job, too.
I'm a strategist in the
operations group at Hattery,
which is a venture capital
firm in San Francisco.
And we see entrepreneurs every
day and work alongside some of
them that are immigrant
founders and
entrepreneurs that are--
while they're building their
product and building a
business to compete in, doing
it in the United States--
still trying to figure out
their own visa status.
And whether or not they're going
to be able to stay here
or whether they have to go
to their home country or,
frankly, to another country
around the world where the
help wanted sign for
entrepreneurs is out.
Places like Start-Up Chile or
South Korea or Canada or any
of a number of countries around
the world where they've
taken steps to fix their
immigration problems.
And we're losing the advantage
in the United States that
we've had for a very
long time on that.
So yes, it's top-line issue.
It is the top-line issue.
And I think it's one that, in
the new Congress, we hope to
see a lot of movement
on very soon.
DEREK SLATER: We've got a couple
of questions here from
folks watching.
Aaron in Atlanta brings up a
good question, which is,
basically, if you wanted to do
a startup that was about
protecting the free and open
internet, are there
ways you can go?
The social entrepreneurship
route or are there ways to
pursue funding for projects that
are about building tools
that help the internet?
Because another way of looking
at it is, we've talked about
entrepreneurs getting engaged
in Washington.
Are there things they can
do as entrepreneurs--
sorts of companies or
technologies they could be
building that would help
advance this cause?
JOHN LYMAN: Yeah.
I mean, I think that
there are.
And I think that there are ways
that they can go out and
get funding through those.
Kickstarter and Indiegogo
are two platforms.
We worked a lot with
Indiegogo.
We launched a partnership with
them in Germany that allowed
entrepreneurs to go out and
fundraise for their ideas and
get money, I think, a little
bit more easily than they
would have otherwise.
But are there specific
for-profit businesses that
help keep the internet
open and alive?
Yeah, I think there
absolutely are.
I think that any time you create
a company that shows
people that innovation helps
create jobs and make the
economy better and stronger,
I think you're
contributing to that.
So I mentioned Kickstarter
before but as a platform.
But I also mention them as a
company that you could start.
This is something that didn't
exist or wasn't even possible
five years ago-- the idea of
being able to go online and
get funding for an art project
or a piece of hardware that
you wanted to make.
I think legislators
notice that.
notice Uber.
And they realize that, hey yeah,
these are companies that
are going to be the future, and
we understand that we need
to help them evolve, even though
there are a lot of
vested interests that don't
want them around.
I think people are starting to
recognize, yeah, this is a
job, a net job creator, and we
need to make sure that they're
allowed to succeed.
MICHAEL MCGEARY: Yeah, I think
the access to capital part is
key in that.
We look at the free and open
internet, and the one thing
that always springs to my mind
is the internet is the
greatest force for
democratization of ideas,
really, in the history
of the world.
And now, when we add better
access to capital to that and
more benefit to social
entrepreneurship, I think that
there's a lot of ideas
that can take flight.
One of the things, as we built
Engine over the course of the
last year or so, has been
whether or not we want to
build tools in house or whether
we want to work with
other startups and leverage the
tools that they've built,
and we've had a combination
of that.
But there's a lot of great
tools out there from--
whether it's POPVOX or some of
the things that are happening
over at Center for Rights and
Fight for the Future and
groups like that in the
digital innovation and
activism spaces.
Well, there are lots of places
that we can plug in and work
together and help to promote
each other and help to promote
these tools that are
being built.
So I think there's a lot of
good happening in terms of
social enterprise in that way.
And I think that the more that
there's access to capital to
make those products a reality,
the more that we'll be able to
use them and other
groups like us.
And that can only be a good
thing as we continue to build
our sites and our products
moving forward.
DEREK SLATER: And Mike, Mark
in Palo Alto wants to know,
along with access to capital and
immigration, what are the
other issues you're going
to be working
on in the next year?
And also, are other ways that--
this is a developer
audience-- can they get involved
with Engine in some
way or somewhere that
they can join?
Or, how does that work?
How does membership work?
MICHAEL MCGEARY: Well, Mark from
Palo Alto, first I'd like
to take you out for a beer and
thank you for that question.
The second thing is that yes,
you can join us at engine dot
is online or engine
advocacy dot org.
We've got a site up
there that's--
we're putting a lot of great
content on every day, talking
about the issues that matter,
the community.
We're going to keep our focus on
those issues, keep writing
and researching about them,
whether it's the economic
impact of startups overall
in the tech community.
Some of the other issues we're
working on besides
immigration--
like I said, we're working on
better investment in STEM
education in the long term.
Things like access to quality
spectrum and broadband, trying
to bring things like Google
Fiber to places beyond Kansas
City or other projects like that
in order to make better
access to better,
faster internet
possible for more people.
We're also working
on patent issues.
And this is one that I think we
might see a lot of movement
on in the new Congress
as well.
Of course, Congress just went
through a multi-year process
to pass the American
Invents Act.
We think that there's a lot
more that Congress can do,
that the regulatory agencies
can do as well, in terms of
how that goes into force and how
we think about patents in
the software space
and with internet
businesses in general.
And I think that there's some
room there for a lot of
advocacy from the developer
community and from engineers,
who may, themselves, have gone
out and gotten patents or work
in companies where that's
a priority as well.
And trying to look at different
legislative
alternatives to solve some
of the morass around
non-practicing entities and
other problems having to do
with the patent community.
So there's a lot that you
can find out about
on engine dot is.
I encourage you to go
there and sign up.
DEREK SLATER: That brings us
to the end of today's show.
Thanks again for joining us.
Tomorrow, I will be back to talk
with civil society groups
from around the world--
the [? IT, ?] you, and
internet freedom.
We'll talk to you then.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]